Britain is famous for its thick fog
ghosts and haunted mansions so
rolls-royce has aptly named its new
coupe a the Wraith Scottish for ghost or
spirit almost without a sound and glides
through the fog no rolls has ever been
this fast or powerful weighing in at
just 2.4 tons and with 465 kilowatts of
power the Wraith is a rolls-royce with a
difference it gives the brand a whole
new dynamism for 110 years the name
rolls-royce has been synonymous with
luxury motorcars right from the start
the firm's founders Charles rolls Henry
Royce lived by the motto take the best
that exists and make it better when it
does not exist design
Afghans are 30 quality Horst Mueller
otras tells us that a rules offers
quality incredible luxury and what they
call the magic carpet ride he claims
that a rolls-royce floats down the
street and boasts a driving experience
that's tough to put into words and of
course all that's combined with an
extraordinary design a radiator grill
that's like the pantheon and the world's
most famous hood ornament the Spirit of
Ecstasy all those things combined make
the brand so exciting until now rolls
has housed it's technologically perfect
parts inside sedans like the ghost and
the Phantom but now the Spirit of
Ecstasy is gracing another kind of car
entirely the bull rolls-royce rape van
fuck'em torsten says the fastback coupe
a is a completely new product for the
firm and the most powerful rolls-royce
ever built the vehicle is also meant to
appeal to people who take the wheel
themselves the ultimate gentlemen's
grand turrent as the English say he
feels it's the GT for the true
connoisseur and it will help the company
attract a new client alkaloid some
coca-cola's horse s he's in bed more
casually dressed than most roles drivers
this one gets in and closes the huge
coach door quietly with a push of a
button
the Wraiths engine is more sonorous and
powerful than that of the company's
other models and spite of its ample
horsepower the car still offers the
comfort you'd expect from a rolls thanks
to its state-of-the-art suspension
technology inside there's barely a sound
to be heard the Wraith exudes the peace
and charm of a British gentlemen's club
at tea time it takes curves almost like
a sports car while oozing elegance and
dynamism sense of fleeting this fleeting
spirit slightly ethereal slightly
enigmatic we wanted to capture certainly
in the design language this sort of
sense of effortless grace and elegance
but at the same time something we'll
contemporary a little bit more daring in
the roofline it's fastback silhouette
really connects with the incisive
dynamic qualities this is a Rolls Royce
solutioning the tie so to speak and the
name Wraith brings a little bit of a
noir to that recipe the iron fist in a
velvet glove the powers there and if you
want it it'll be pretty potent
that sleek body houses a six-litre
twin-turbo v12 that even close to idling
has almost as much thrust as to Porsche
911s yet the engine runs so smoothly it
passes the old coin test
while standing still rolls-royce
describes the Wraith as an athlete and
the starting blocks but this car is no
wiry sprinter it's a muscular decathlete
yet in spite of its bulk the Wraith goes
like the wind
Oh
the sporty coupe is interior is hand
crafted using the finest of materials
the slightly thicker steering wheel is
easy to grip allowing the driver to
maneuver the 2.4 ton vehicle with ease
and for 10,000 euros extra buyers can
even have the Wraiths roof fitted with a
starlight headliner featuring 1340 mini
LEDs hand sewn into the leather it gives
the car's occupants their own personal
night sky via the large HD screen
located in the dashboard drivers can
raise the price to hood ornament or
lower it for safety reasons in spite of
its luxurious interior the Wraith is a
real workhorse and winding country roads
are its preferred to rain the car
employs satellite-aided transmission
technology using GPS data it tracks and
anticipates the vehicles movements and
selects the most appropriate gear for
the road ahead the new Wraith is
bringing a breath of fresh air to the
venerable rolls-royce brand and offering
Bentley Ferrari and Aston Martin a run
for their money the rolls-royce Wraith
is truly a spirited car and one of a
kind
you